today for our daily cancellation we
begin with some good news for a change
the philadelphia inquirer has the story
it says the u.s women's soccer team
opened the olympics in disastrous
fashion losing 3-0 to long-time rival
sweden
it was the program's worst defeat at a
major tournament since 2007
and manager vladko andanovsky's first
loss
since taking the helm in october 2019
and it was no fluke it was an
honest-to-goodness beating
for all the talk of the us being the
tournament's heavy favorite sweden was
on the front
foot from the start and rarely let up i
don't really know what that means
they outshot the americans by 16 to 13
in the game including by 10 to 3 in the
first half an american
team loaded with past medals but also
the oldest squad in this tournament
looked the latter more than the former
now from what i'm hearing this is was
almost as embarrassing as the time when
they lost to a bunch of adolescent boys
it's almost it's also almost as
hilarious and wonderful but not quite
i'm not ashamed to tell you that i am
actively rooting against u.s women's
soccer i want them to lose
i want them to be embarrassed badly on
the global stage
because they have so thoroughly and
intentionally embarrassed us
the daily mail reports quote the us and
the u.s
and team gb women's football teams were
among those who
took the knee took the knee ahead of
their opening matches in the olympics
today all
22 players took part in the gesture
prior to kickoff between four-time
olympics champion
the u.s and sweden and tokyo an hour
after team gb and chile did likewise in
sapporo
the ioc recently relaxed the rules for
protests at the game
soffiting a long-standing ban on
political protests at the global
sporting event
athletes will now be allowed to take a
knee before play begins to highlight
racial injustice
speak to the media and post online about
their views or wear clothing with a
protest slogan at a press conference
so u.s women's soccer took the knee as
always
none of them can explain why they're
kneeling none of these people have ever
been able to offer any cogent
explanation
as to what exactly they're protesting
and that's because they aren't
protesting any particular thing so much
as expressing a general disdain
for their country and this stunt comes
as no surprise either these are the same
ladies who wore blm shirts while also
taking a knee
during the anthem before a game last
year led by political activist megan
rapido
they have consistently put their
politics front and center and declined
to display patriotism in favor in favor
of this sort of woke virtue signaling
all while repeatedly declaring their
allegiance with an organization blm
that is among the most destructive evil
and depraved
to exist in this country in modern
history
these women are not interested in
representing the united states
they want to represent their own
ideological interests they have shown
no pride in their country no allegiance
to it and so i have no pride in them
i want them to lose that's what they
deserve
it's true of course that the other women
from the other teams knelt also
um one set of kneelers losing just means
another set wins unfortunately
but those other women are not supposed
to be representing our country
it's not our country that they make a
mockery of if some morons from sweden
want to kneel that's sweden's concern if
morons from the u.s kneel
it's ours this is where we are now and
it's not where i want to be
even though i'm only vaguely interested
in the olympics and i'm not at all
interested in soccer
i still want to root for our teams and
our players
but if you won't stand and show pride in
your country if patriotism is too much
to ask for
if this country has blessed you beyond
measure and still you put your
allegiance to violent marxist
organizations like blm
over your allegiance to the flag then i
am ashamed
to share a country with you and i don't
think you deserve to represent us in
front of the globe
you know there's a lot of gaslighting
that's gone on with this issue of course
those of us who feel this way about it
those of us who are sick to death of the
political statements the kneeling and so
on
we're accused of being the ones to
politicize sports
and if we celebrate the defeat of
athletes who carry on this way
we're accused of being disloyal but
we're not the ones who chose to make
sports into an ideological
battlefield and what we're asking for is
not much
it really isn't all we want is for these
people to conduct themselves with a
little dignity
and to display just the faintest hint of
gratitude
for the country that they live in and
represent and which has given them so
much
if that's too much to ask for
then it's too much to ask us to root for
you
i hope you fail and i'm glad when you do
and also
you're canceled listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated